JUAN WILLIAMS, DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
THIS IS VIDEO OF GEORGE HERBERT
WALKER BUSH WHEN HE CRASHED INTO
THE SEA AS A YOUNG PILOT.
IT'S WHAT WE CALL A HERO.
IF YOU ARE YOUNG PLAYING
VIDEO GAMES, SHOPPING ONLINE OR
FULMINATING ON FACEBOOK, IT'S
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING CALLED
LEISURE TIME AND LEISURE TIME
WAS BROUGHT TO YOU BY MILLIONS
OF MEN AND WOMEN WHOSE BRAVERY
IN TIMES OF WAR MADE OUR IDLE
ACTIVITY POSSIBLE.
I WONDER, WOULD WE EVEN BE HERE
IF IT WEREN'T FOR MEN LIKE HIM?
THE PASSING OF GEORGE HERBERT
WALKER BUSH REMINDS ME OF THE
RECENT PASSING OF JOHN McCAIN.
MEN AND WOMEN UNIFIES PEOPLE.
WE TRY TO FORGET ABOUT THE OTHER
STUFF WHEN REALIZE IT'S
POINTLESS.
PEOPLE COME AND GO ON THE PLANET
AND IN OUR LIVES IT HELPS TO
REMEMBER THAT ALL OF US HAVE
SOMETHING IN COMMON WITH THE
GREAT ONES.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF A FEW
CHUCKLE BUCKETS WHO USE EVENTS
TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS, IT'S
A SHARE LOSS THAT REVEALS HOW WE
REALLY ARE.
NONE OF US TWEETS IN THE FACE OF
DEATH.
KIND    KINDER AND GENTLER.
A GREAT PERSON DIES WE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THE RITUALS.
IT'S NOT A BAD THING TO USE THE
PASSING OF A GREAT MAN HAS AN
EXCUSE TO MAKE LIFE BETTER.
LESS FINGER-POINTING.
MORE HANDSHAKES.
I'M SURE WE'LL GET TO OUR TRIBES
BUT FOR NOW LET'S DO THE GUY A
FAVOR.
BE KIND AND GENTLE IN CASE HE IS
WATCHING.
DANA, I AM SITTING IN YOUR CHAIR
WHICH I FEEL QUITE STRANGE.
>> Jesse: SO DO I.
>> Greg: I DON'T LIKE BEING
THIS CLOSE TO JESSE.
>> Jesse: TOPPED STOP TOU
>> Jesse: TOPPED STOP TOH
>> Jesse: TOPPED STOP TON
>> Jesse: TOPPED STOP TOG
>> Jesse: TOPPED STOP TOM
>> Jesse: TOPPED STOP TOE
UNDER THE TABLE.
>> Greg: THE IRREVERENCE
LASTED TEN SECONDS.
DANA, YOU ARE IN D.C.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Dana: IT'S OBVIOUSLY AN
HONOR TO BE HERE AND TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE KNOWN THEM AND TALK
ABOUT THEM.
YOUR MONOLOGUE WAS SPOT ON.
A COUPLE THINGS THAT TOUCHED ME
TODAY.
I GOT A CHANCE TO INTERVIEW
VICE PRESIDENT DAN QUAYLE AND TO
LOOK BACK IN 1988 WHEN HE GAVE
THE CONVENTION SPEECH.
OF COURSE I REMEMBER THAT TIME.
I'M SURE YOU DO TOO.
MAYBE JESSE DOESN'T.
MAYBE LISA BOOTHE WASN'T PAYING
ATTENTION THERE, BECAUSE SHE IS
SO YOUNG AS WELL.
YOU REALIZE THINGS CHANGE.
PARTIES EVOLVE.
PEOPLE HAVE A WAY OF SORT OF
FORGETTING WHAT THINGS WERE LIKE
BACK THEN.
MOMENTS LIKE THIS ALLOW YOU A
CHANCE TO PAUSE.
THE MOMENT THAT TOUCHED ME TODAY
WAS WHEN SENATOR BOB DOLE WENT
TO THE CAPITAL.
HE'S 95 YEARS OLD.
AS YOU SEE THERE, HE'S HELPED BY
AN ASSISTANT TO STAND SO THAT HE
COULD PROPERLY AND IN HIS WAY TO
PAY HIS RESPECTS TO
GEORGE H.W. BUSH, WHO WAS A VERY
GOOD FRIEND OF HIS.
OF COURSE THEY WERE COMPETITORS
BUT FRIENDLY COMPETITORS.
GREG, I THINK LAST WEEK WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE GREATEST
GENERATION.
I'M SORRY, IT WAS ANDY
FERGUSON'S PIECE.
HE WAS A FRIEND OF YOURS AND A
SPEECHWRITER FOR
GEORGE H.W. BUSH AND HE WROTE
ABOUT A SPEECH HE HAD TO GIVE IN
WHICH, IN 1982 DURING HIS
REELECTION, THE POLITICAL
CONSULTANT SAID DON'T TALK ABOUT
HIS WAR SERVICE.
DON'T LET HIM TALK ABOUT HIS WAR
SERVICE BECAUSE IT WILL MAKE HIM
LOOK TO OLD IN COMPARISON TO
BILL CLINTON.
THEN, FOUR WEEKS BEFORE THE
ELECTION, THE POLITICAL
CONSULTANTS CHANGED THEIR MIND
AND SAID MAYBE WE SHOULD
HIGHLIGHT HIS WAR SERVICE.
HE WRITES THIS TEACHING THAT THE
END OF IT, HE SAYS, IN THE
ARTICLE HE WROTE, FERGUSON SAYS
"NEARLY ALL OF THEM ARE GONE
NOW."
I THINK MAYBE THAT'S WHY IT
FEELS VERY POIGNANT.
THIS GREATEST GENERATION, WE ARE
HAVING TO SAY GOODBYE TO THEM.
>> Greg: IT'S NOT JUST
MR. BUSH, IT'S WHO HE
SYMBOLIZES, MILLIONS OF MEN THAT
ARE NO LONGER HERE.
JUAN, YOU WORKED, YOU ARE AT THE
POST IN '88?
YOU PROBABLY RAN INTO
PRESIDENT BUSH WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT OR VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: HE WAS
VICE PRESIDENT, THAT'S WHEN I
SPEND MOST OF THE TIME WITH HIM.
FLYING AROUND THE COUNTRY GOING
TO REPUBLICAN EVENTS, TRYING TO
GET RONALD REAGAN REELECTED.
I HAD A WONDERFUL TIME.
IT WAS KIND OF LIKE BEING AT THE
FEET OF THE MASTER BECAUSE YOU
TALK ABOUT A POLITICAL -- HE HAD
BEEN HEAD OF THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE IN ADDITION
TO RUNNING TWICE FOR
SENATOR UNSUCCESSFULLY BUT THEN
HOLDING A HOUSE EAT TWICE FROM
HOUSTON.
HE HAD BEEN THROUGH A LOT
POLITICALLY.
HE KNEW THE POLITICAL LEADERSHIP
GOING BACK TO THE GOLDWATER DAYS
OF '64.
YOU TALK ABOUT A REPUBLICAN
PARTY EXPERT IN TERMS OF, I WAS
SAYING HE'S FAMOUS FOR WRITING
NOTES TO PEOPLE AND I'M SURE
DANA HAS A TON.
I HAVE SOME.
HE WOULD WRITE NOTES TO ALL THE
PARTY LEADER SO THAT THEY FELT
THEY HAD A PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH HIM.
THE AXIOM HERE WAS DON'T CALL
SOMEBODY UP TO ASK A FAVOR,
POLITICAL FAVOR, PERSONAL FAVOR,
RIGHT OUT OF THE BOX WITHOUT
SAYING HOW ARE YOU DOING?
HOW ARE YOU?
HOW ARE THE KIDS?
THAT'S THE RELATIONSHIP HE HAD,
SO THAT EVEN THE PEOPLE
DISAGREED WITH HIM, SPECIFICALLY
I WOULD GUESS IN THIS DAY HAVE
TRIBES COME IF YOU SAY, GREG,
THE DEMOCRATS.
OH, MY GOSH.
DEMOCRATS HAD A PRETTY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
DIDN'T ALWAYS COME TO GOOD
POLITICAL ENDS BECAUSE REMEMBER
IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET DEAL
WHERE HE ALLOWED TAXES TO BE
RAISED IN ORDER TO LOWER THE
DEFICIT, IT WAS HELD AGAINST HIM
BY SOME IN THE PARTY, ESPECIALLY
THE FAR RIGHT, THE NEWT GINGRICH
TYPES WHO SAID YOU ARE BREAKING
YOUR PLEDGE NOT TO RAISE TAXES.
READ MY LIPS, NO NEW TAXES.
BUT THIS IS AN EXAMPLE, I KEEP
SAYING THAT I WOULD HOLD UP TO
MY CHILDREN IS THAT KIND OF
PERSON THAT YOU WANT TO BE.
SOMEONE WHO IS ABOUT PUBLIC
SERVICE, LOVE OF COUNTRY, LOVE
OF FAMILY, AND TREATED PEOPLE AS
INDIVIDUALS, NOT AS I AM
GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
WHO ARE YOU?
NO, IT WAS LIKE TELL ME ABOUT
YOU.
>> Jesse: SOME PERSONAL
REFLECTIONS.
I CAME UP UNDER THE AGE OF BUSH,
HE WAS IN THE VICE PRESIDENCY
WHEN I WAS YOUNG AND THEN THE
PRESIDENCY AND THAT HIS SON'S
PRESIDENCY.
A GREAT STATESMAN IN AMERICA.
JUST A FEW THINGS COME TO MIND.
HUMILITY, DIGNITY, CLASS, AND
LOVE.
YOU TALK ABOUT HE OVERSAW
AMERICA WINNING THE COLD WAR.
THAT WAS A TIME WHEN HE COULD
HAVE SAID AMERICA SHOULD JUST
BEAT OUR CHESTS AND GLOAT AND
SPIKE THE FOOTBALL.
INSTEAD, HE DIDN'T.
HE SAID ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
THE SILENCE WAS VERY IMPORTANT
AT THAT TIME, THERE WAS A VERY
POWERFUL MOMENT.
I THINK HE WAS RAISED IN THE
PREP SCHOOL, BOARDING SCHOOL ERA
WHERE GOOD SPORTSMANSHIP IS
DRILLED INTO YOU.
HE ALWAYS WON WITH CLASS AND
DIGNITY.
ALSO WHEN HE KICKED SADDAM OUT
OF KUWAIT, HE HAD THE ABILITY TO
RUSH TO BAGHDAD AND OVERTAKE THE
ENTIRE GOVERNMENT AND HE WAS
HUMBLE ENOUGH TO KNOW THE
LIMITATIONS OF AMERICAN MILITARY
POWER.
I THINK EVERYONE, REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS, LOOK BACK AND SAY
THAT WAS A WISE AND HUMBLE AND
NOBLE DECISION.
JUAN PICKED UP ON A FEW THINGS.
THE PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS HE
HAD WITH PEOPLE, PROFESSIONAL
RELATIONSHIPS, FRIENDSHIPS.
HE REALLY CONDUCTED IN A CLASSY
WAY, COMMUNICATED ON STATIONARY,
PICKING UP THE PHONE.
HE DID THAT FOR SO MANY DECADES
THAT HE GENERATED SO MUCH
GOODWILL.
TOWARDS THE END MET COME THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WAS THE PARTY
OF BUSH.
THE ROLODEX, ALL THE PEOPLE HE
KNEW, THE NETWORKS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY, THEY HAD SO MUCH
HONOR AND REVERENCE FOR HIM AND
HIS FAMILY.
WHEN HE CALLED AND ASKED FOR
SOMETHING, IT WAS SURE, NOT A
POLITICAL FAVOR.
YOU ARE DOING SOMETHING FOR A
FRIEND.
LASTLY, LOVE.
IN TERMS OF HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH BARBARA AND HIS SONS
PUBLICLY AT LEAST, YOU WOULD
THINK A MAN OF HIS GENERATION
WOULDN'T BE CONDITIONED TO SHOW
THAT KIND OF AFFECTION TOWARDS
OTHER PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY HIS
FAMILY, IN PUBLIC.
BUT HIS LOVE AND AFFECTION, THE
WAY HE DISPLAYED IT, WAS VERY
MODERN.
HE WASN'T AFRAID OF EMBRACING
PEOPLE AND CRYING AND
ARTICULATING THAT LOVE.
I THINK EVERY FATHER AND EVERY
SOUND IN THIS COUNTRY SHOULD
LOOK AT THE RELATIONSHIP THAT HE
HAD WITH HIS SONS AND SAY THAT
IS HOW A TRUE FATHER-SON
RELATIONSHIP SHOULD BE.
>> Lisa: I FOUND MYSELF THIS
WEEK READING HIS LETTERS, AND I
THINK THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH TALK
ABOUT HIS INTEGRITY, KINDNESS,
THE KIND OF MAN HE WAS.
IF YOU READ HIS LETTERS, YOU CAN
SEE IT.
THE WRITTEN WORD ALWAYS LASTS A
MUCH LONGER THAN WHAT YOU SAY
MTV OR WHAT YOU SAY DURING A
DEBATE OR WHAT HAVE YOU.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING FOR HIM
BECAUSE WHAT A BEAUTIFUL LEGACY
TO LEAVE BEHIND.
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE TALKED
ABOUT THIS YESTERDAY WHEN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, WHEN HE WROTE
A LETTER TO HIS SON WHEN HE
LANDED HIS FIRST TAIL HOOK
LANDING AS A MARINE AVIATOR,
SAYING HE SHARES THE PRIDE THAT
MIKE PENCE HAS IN HIS SON.
THE LETTER HE LEFT BILL CLINTON,
YOU ARE OUR PRESIDENT, AND I'M
ROOTING FOR YOU.
EVEN THOUGH HE DEFEATED HIM AND
HE WAS A ONE TERM PRESIDENT.
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL THING TO HAVE
THAT CHARACTER AND LEAVE THAT
MESSAGE TO BILL CLINTON.
YOU LOOK AT THE LOVE LETTERS TO
BARBARA AND WHAT A BEAUTIFUL,
LOVING RELATIONSHIP THEY HAD.
THE LETTER THAT HE WROTE ABOUT
HIS DAUGHTER ROBIN, WHO THEY
LOST, TALKING ABOUT THE FACT
THAT SHE'S ALWAYS GOING TO
REMAIN WITH THEM.
ALL OF THESE LETTERS, WHAT A
BEAUTIFUL LEGACY FOR HIM TO
LEAVE BEHIND.
FOR FUTURE AMERICANS TO SEE IS A
KIND OF INTEGRITY THAT THE MAN
HAD.
>> Juan: DANA, WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TOMORROW AT THE FUNERAL?
>> Dana: YOU WILL HAVE
EULOGIES FROM GEORGE W. BUSH.
THAT WILL BE HARD FOR ME TO GET
THROUGH BECAUSE I AM QUITE CLOSE
TO HIM, AS CHRISTOPHER BUCKLEY,
ANOTHER SPEECHWRITER WROTE, THAT
THEY MIGHT'VE BEEN NEW ENGLAND
ROOTS BUT THEY HAVE BIG TEAR
DUCTS OF A SICILIAN GRANDMOTHER.
THEN BRIAN MULRONEY, THE
PRIME MINISTER OF CANADA,
1 OF 41'S BEST FRIENDS ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
ALAN SIMPSON FROM THE GREAT
STATE OF WYOMING WILL ALSO YOU
EULOGIZE HIM AND THEN JOHN
MEACHAM, THE STORY           THE
MEACHAM, THE STORY           THS
MEACHAM, THE STORY           THO
MEACHAM, THE STORY           THY
MEACHAM, THE STORY           TH.
GREG, YOU AND I'VE SAID THIS.
41 REALLY EMBODIED THIS MACHINE